Alright!
How's it going bro's, my name is PewDiePie *Hi*
We just did some crazy climbing
That was f*cking insane
And now ...We're gonna go down
Welcome back to Uncharted 4
We play this game every single day
And if you check in now, go to check out Part 1 *What?*
And catch up, and do shit I don't f*cking know
All right, I'm so excited to be playing
It's been a while since I played
Because I had to go away on holiday
Yeah, my life is rough, I know
Holiday from playing games
People don't realize the struggle
In my life
Ha, we found the coin *All of the lols*
Someone is gonna die in this game *Oh really?*
You just know it
And I'm worried it's gonna be Gramps
Wait *No*
So you're telling me we couldn't have reception before
But underneath the f*cking ground we can reach him?!
Get out of here!
This is very pretty, no one has been here in a while
I can tell
Alright
We're looking for the treasure
It should be in one of the towers
and we are in the right tower
Oh, there is Avery's sigil
All right, there's the skull
Sure - surely there is a trap? *Maybe*
Ooooh, it's another puzzle
I - love - puzzles! *I don't*
So cool, this game actually makes me want to learn about history and sh*t
Okay, so that's their sigils. This is the puzzle. Let's click and see what happens.
Founders
Stop copying me.
Okay, so we can - ooohh!
They turn...
Are you kidding me that was it?
Another puzzle *Dammit*
Could be a trap
Its like gaming avatars like back in the day
Uuuuuuuhm....
I can rotate these as well
But uuh it seems less obvious how they are going to be made
I mean I don't really see it
I think that could work
Oh guess I'm just f*cking tired again
Uhhm...
I can only rotate them, that's the only thing I can do
Okay, we'll have a look
This one points to the right
This one points up
Or does it point down?
F*ck it, I don't know
Shut up game, I'm thinking
Wait what, I wasn't actually supposed to solve anything? *I guess not*
Are you for real? *Yes*
Ah, so we get the clues here
Are you kidding me?
Man they have so much better names back then
Cun-Condent, Baldridge!
I guess those names still exist actually, nevermind
Almost
That's alright
Hmm
Nada...
Nuh uh...
mmmmmmmmm nnnnEh?
Ohh *What is it*
That's the clue. Alright let's see the other clue
Okay, I got it
So glad I wasted my time f*cking spinning them around for 30 minutes, Jesus Christ
Thanks, game. * You're welcome* Oh okay so I can... I can figure it out here
Rotate, there we go
*sings*
Put away
Oh this is so cool
*sings* *Please stop*
Well this one is used to be centered
I don't know if I can actually move them
Then we put that one there, no way that doesn't make sense
Like that? *I don't know*
What?
Okay, well let's make su-
Okay, it has to be like this so...
Like this then. Okay its simple *Yes simple...*
Alright it's simple. You just f*cking put them together
It's not... it's not a big deal
I don't... eehh
Just put it.. just put
*Wut?*
That's it, you did it Nate
Nice flipping there Nate
You did it - boom shakalak
Why do I do this in here?
Did you cut those out while we were talking?
You are so crafty
That looks f*cking awesome
Alright well let's f*cking give it a go, I suppose
Can I inspect my book?
Yeah I can, alright...so
Uuuuuuuuuhm *Let's make a beat out of it*
I got it
Seriously?! *LOL*
F*ck you I was so close
Another one *Haha I get it*
Okay well I...
Yeah, gimme your phone
No, I'm gonna look up Google
Heyyy
I'ma take a picture of my *something*
Can we take a picture of- hey
Ahaha
*More lols*
Oh I wanna get him
*Weird noises 101* That's so cute
Hey I got an achivment for that! *Trophy*
That's so cool *More laugh*
Uhhh...
Du hast eine trophäe erhalten! *Not racist*
Thank you
*Gasp*
This is actually.. That is actually a good point
I like how the game...
Thinks like that
What do you mean "nuh uh"?
I see those right f*cking there, dude
Alright, well- oh its here, sorry *Face palm*
They tried and trick you, man *I don't really think so*
Richard Want, William Mayes
Oooh I got a teeext
Man, its gotta suck to be in a different tower if it finally...
William Mayes, what a place
To bathe *wtf?*
Alright so we don't actually-
Aw damn, I thought...
Its the same puzzle, twice, come on man!
Come on man! *Very manly, Pewds*
Who the hell cares?
I mean, when you got a hat like that...
When you got a hat-
Taking a sh*t, probably
I assume they still did that, back in the day *I'd hope so*
Okay, I can't actually find the square on this one
Ah, there it is
Alright,  uhh.. Nate of course has cut them all out for us
Thank you very much, Nate
Look at his diary, its so cute
Look at all this sh*t
Ador-
Adorable
Alright, well, we're not here to judge Nate for his items
Okay this one is a lil trickier, guys
Uhm,  I don't know if we can do this *Well I mean... we can. Its you that can't*
Uhm, okay, I suppose we start with the centered piece